aquí tenemos la gráfica de la función y
es igual a x cuadrada bueno de hecho es
sólo una parte de la gráfica y la
primera cosa que quiero abordar en este
vídeo es la tasa de cambio de ye con
respecto a x en el intervalo desde el x
igual a uno hasta x igual a 3 así que
déjame escribirlo queremos la tasa de
cambio promedio
james con respecto a x la tasa de cambio
promedio con respecto a x en el
intervalo 1,13 en el intervalo cerrado
13 es decir x puede tomar el valor de 1
y también puede tomar el valor de 3
bueno nosotros podremos saber la
respuesta incluso sin ver la gráfica si
hacemos una tabla por acá donde aquí
tengamos a equis y aquí tengamos a james
que es igual a equis cuadrada entonces
podemos decir que cuando x vale 1
llévale bueno 1 al cuadrado lo cual es
uno lo puedes ver justo aquí observa la
gráfica y cuando x vale 3 bueno y es
igual a 3 al cuadrado lo cual es 9 y lo
podemos ver acá cuando x vale 3 y vale 9
y para encontrar la tasa de cambio de
que con respecto a x entonces decimos
primero cuál es mi cambio en x bueno
claramente podemos ver que mi cambio en
x en este intervalo es de 2 positivo y
ahora cuál es el cambio en james en este
mismo intervalo bueno nuestro cambio va
a ser igual vamos desde 1 hasta 9 es
decir que cuando nosotros vamos en x de
1 a 3
podemos decir que nosotros incrementamos
de 1 a 9 en game y tenemos un cambio de
8 de 8 positivo entonces cuál es la tasa
de cambio de que con respecto a x va a
ser igual a 8 entre 2 lo cual va a ser
igual a 4 es decir que en este intervalo
en promedio cada vez que aumentamos x en
1 vamos a aumentar allí en 4 y como lo
calculamos bueno recuerda que si sólo
nos fijamos en el cambio en x si lo
dibujamos sería este de aquí
y ahora déjame dibujar nuestro cambio en
james y entonces tenemos un cambio en
que con respecto a x ahora seguramente
esto te parece familiar porque si
hablamos del cambio en que con respecto
a x en el contexto de una recta esto nos
da la idea de la pendiente de la recta
que conecta dos puntos y esto de hecho
es lo que calculamos si dibujamos la
recta secante entre estos dos puntos
bueno esencialmente lo que hicimos fue
calcular la pendiente de esta recta
secante por lo tanto la tasa de cambio
entre dos puntos es lo mismo que la
pendiente de la recta secante que pasa
por esos dos puntos y viendo esta recta
secante comparada con la curva en el
mismo intervalo nos da una intuición
visual de lo que significa una tasa de
cambio promedio observa que en la parte
inicial del intervalo puedes ver que la
recta secante está creciendo con una
tasa más rápida que la curva de amarillo
y cuando se acerca tres parece que la
curva de amarillo está creciendo con una
tasa de cambio
más rápida que la recta secante y de
hecho eventualmente alcanza la recta
secante y esa es la razón por la cual la
pendiente de nuestra recta secante es la
tasa de cambio promedio del intervalo si
te preguntas si es la tasa de cambio
exactamente en cada uno de los puntos
bueno pues la respuesta es no la tasa de
cambio de la curva está cambiando
constantemente es una tasa de cambio
menor en la parte inicial del intervalo
lo puedes ver aquí y después aumenta a
una tasa de cambio más rápida conforme
nos acercamos al final del intervalo así
que sobre el intervalo el cambio en que
con respecto a x no siempre es el mismo
ahora bien una pregunta que seguramente
te aqueja es porque tenemos que aprender
esto en una clase de cálculo no sería
más fácil aprender todo esto en una
clase de álgebra bueno la respuesta
sería sí pero lo que va a ser muy
interesante es que uno de los
fundamentos bases del cálculo es
preguntarse qué pasa si estos puntos se
empiezan a acercar más y más y más el
uno al otro
ya encontramos la tasa de cambio entre 1
y 3 la pendiente de la recta secante
entre esos dos puntos el punto 11 y el
punto 39 pero qué pasaría si en su lugar
encontramos la tasa de cambio o la
pendiente de la recta secante entre los
puntos 24 y 39 cuál será su pendiente o
más aún qué pasaría si nos acercamos un
poco más y encontramos la pendiente de
la recta secante
entre los puntos 2.5 6.25 y 3,9 es más
qué pasaría si no seguimos acercando más
y más más más bueno pues las pendientes
de las rectas secantes se acercarían más
y más y más a la pendiente de la recta
tangente en x igual a 3 y si pudiéramos
encontrar la pendiente de la recta
tangente entonces estamos en la misma
sintonía porque ojo entonces ya no
estaríamos hablando de la tasa de cambio
promedio estaríamos hablando de la tasa
de cambio instantánea lo cual es una de
las ideas centrales de lo que es la
derivada y eso
vamos a ver muy pronto pero realmente es
importante que aprecies que la tasa de
cambio promedio entre dos puntos es lo
mismo que encontrar la pendiente de la
recta secante y si estos dos puntos se
empiezan a acercar más y más y más y más
y por lo tanto la recta secante empieza
conectar puntos que estén cada vez más
juntos es decir si la distancia entre
esos dos puntos aproxima cero
bueno pasan cosas muy interesantes y
todo esto lo seguiremos viendo en el
siguiente vídeo